[Música]
y en directo a vamos a ir a Perú donde
el consejo de ministros aprobó este
miércoles declarar en estado de
emergencia durante 60 días a los
distritos cercanos al volcán uvinas al
sur del país que recordemos que se
encuentra desde el martes pasado en
etapa eruptiva y que ha llegado a
expulsar columnas de humo y cenizas a
más de 5 kilómetros de altura y para
abordar este tema nos acompaña desde
Lima nuestro corresponsal Francisco
zagarías muy buenas noches Francisco
Bienvenido a directo a contanos cuál es
la condición de alarma por el volcán
uvinas y qué acciones comprende este
estado de emergencia declarado por el
gobierno
Buenas noches Santiago las autoridades
llevan el registro de diecisiete
explosiones y más de
170 sismos de tipo volcánico tectónico
relacionados a la ruptura de rocas que
se producen al interior del volcán
uvinas las gases y las cenizas están
siendo desplazados a otras localidades
de la región moquegua ubicada al sur del
Perú se reporta que diez poblados se
encuentran en riesgo ante la inminente
erupción y para atender esta emergencia
el Primer Ministro Alberto botárola ha
dispuesto que una comisión
multisectorial encabezada por la
ministra de transportes y comunicaciones
Paola lasarte se traslade hacia la zona
de urbinas para atender y asistir a esta
emergencia y también desplegar planes
para el control de daños las autoridades
regionales están adelantando que serían
alrededor de dos mil pobladores que
tienen que ser evacuados pero se
resisten a ser reubicados porque en
lugar de prestarle mayor preocupación
por sus vidas le están prestando mayor
interés por el cuidado de sus terrenos
sus cultivos y su ganado Precisamente en
esta emergencia también se denuncia que
el albergue de ziraguaya que se tenía
previsto
ser utilizado ante esta situación se
encuentra totalmente abandonado desde el
año 2019 y tal como lo señalan algunos
pobladores de la localidad carece de
servicios básicos como son el agua el
desagüe y la luz eléctrica así como un
poco nos lo adelantabas recién pero
quisiera que nos des más información
sobre cuál es la situación de los
pobladores que están cerca del volcán y
también sobre las repercusiones que
generan las explosiones de ceniza y
gases del volcán
justamente en Los poblados cercanos a la
zona de influencia del volcán uvinas las
calles las plazas los techos de las
casas se encuentran cubiertos por
cenizas y precisamente el instituto
geofísico del Perú adelantado que Los
Fuertes vientos del sur están
trasladando ceniza y material volcánico
a zonas de cultivo y poblaciónes
indígenas que habitan por la periferia y
justamente el temor de tanto de las
autoridades como de los pobladores es
que estas cenizas este material tóxico
caiga en los pastos y los animales
puedan contaminarse y morir al consumir
estos pastos contaminados y justamente
otra de las preocupaciones es que los
ríos las lagunas las fuentes de agua al
ser
digamos contaminadas por las cenizas
volcánicas puedan convertirse en fuentes
de ácido y justamente
que la autoridad Nacional del Agua ha
empleado una acción inmediata para
tratar de hacer un descarte de las
fuentes de agua y establecer Cuáles son
saludables para que la población no se
vea afectada pero la magnitud de estas
cenizas que se están
trasladando otras zonas del Perú podrían
llegar a la región de puno fronteriza
con Bolivia algunos pobladores de la
provincia del callao han alertado a
través de medios de esa localidad que
han visto restos de material volcánico
en sus pastizales y ellos temen que sus
ganados que son la principal fuente
económica para ellos puedan morir y
ellos también verse afectado con sus
fuentes de agua y recursos naturales